tensión y caras largas en el congreso de
España después de que este martes se
aprobara finalmente la reforma a la ley
sólo sí es sí se toma En consideración
la proposición de ley un nuevo
desencuentro entre el psoe y unidas
podemos partidos de la coalición
gobernante que abre una brecha cada vez
más grande entre ellos el motivo por el
que lo hacemos Es claro responder ante
las víctimas la ley de la libertad
sexual o solo sí es sí surgió a raíz de
La indignación que causó el caso de la
manada cuando en 2016 un grupo de
hombres violó a una mujer
[Aplausos]
algo que abre un debate en torno a si
hubo o no consentimiento por no decir
explícitamente no la legislación
impulsada por podemos y aprobada en
agosto de 2022 quería acabar con estos
planteamientos solo Sí o sí sin margen
para dudas la ley unificó los delitos de
agresión sexual y abuso sexual
definiendo que todo acto sexual sin
consentimiento es una agresión con o sin
violencia ahora la reforma del psoe
rescata la importancia de la violencia
al diferenciar la agresión sexual con o
sin ella con el objetivo de aumentar las
condenas estamos dispuestos a negociar
para reducir el margen de
interpretabilidad de la ley estamos
dispuestas a subir las penas Aunque no
queramos una ley punitivista estamos
dispuestas a admitir cambios lo que no
vamos a permitir es que se saque el
consentimiento del centro de la ley en
paralelo a esta discusión se aprobó un
anteproyecto de ley de paridad de género
que obligará a una representación a más
igualitaria en el ámbito público y
privado impulsada por el psoe que rompe
el techo de cristal en el ámbito público
y privado y consolida a España como uno
de los países más avanzados en igualdad
de género a nivel mundial movimientos
que los expertos opinan se asemejan a
una competición un tira y afloja entre
los partidos socios de gobierno para
poderse de la bandera feminista de Cara
a este 8 de marzo